Michael what's in these rules it's good
and what's in these rules of bed well
I'd say that the fact that we have rules
is in and of itself great because it
gives us a platform upon which to build
i would say that there are some problems
to the extent that the rules will
prohibit operations of commercial
operations of UAVs and drones when there
are personnel on the ground that are not
associated with the project which
essentially will shift all commercial
usage so that's that's a real problem
there are also some suggestions that
there will there will not be the ability
to operate outside the line of sight
which means that it has to be a visual I
the actual person has to be able to see
the use of the whole die so the very
notion of the the Amazon drone that
brings you your box and drops it at your
front door and hopefully doesn't clip
your your poodle that's out with this
proposal yeah i mean that's out this
exactly and i think what most people
believe and i think it's true is that
automation is going to be the future of
this industry for delivery for you know
precision agriculture for you know
pipeline inspections for disaster
management search and rescue there's a
whole host of purposes that UAVs can be
used for and I think we have some work
to do now but the one thing I'll say is
that the FAA was was was great and not
touching the ability of recreational
users to enjoy UAVs for aerial
photography and digital photography it's
wonderful yeah but CB insights just came
out with report today that showed that
there were over 100 million dollars
invested in a drone business in the last
year a hundred million dollars no one's
doing that because they want another
frisbee I mean the whole idea right is
hey we can find a cheaper way and a
safer way to inspect or at least a
cheaper way may be safer as well to
inspect pipe
lines that we can you know that which
have to be inspected to check for leaks
and there are things that that can be
done so much more often because the cost
would be so much lower is there a sense
that the FAA doesn't want that happening
no I back to quite the contrary the FAA
and the evaluation of the proposed rule
said that you know they are going to
save lives this is efficient and in fact
they said that UAVs can be used for you
know cell tower inspection pipeline
inspections things that are producing
you know fatalities now which can be
stopped with the utilization of this
technology so there's a lot of promise
here and I think the only thing we have
to keep in mind is that this is a
proposed rule so it'll take you know a
series of months if I'm hopeful that we
can get it done as quickly as possible
but I don't think it'll be this year and
other countries are already operating
commercially even outside the line of
sight so we are we are still far behind
other nations in terms of privacy what
do we want from rules about drones you
know you work for to the companies that
support you amazon and google have
notions of privacy that are different
between them let alone different from
what other people might want yeah so
privacy's of paramount importance I
think we all recognize that and you know
the the administration and the president
put an executive order which we thought
was very thoughtful on the issue of
privacy uh you know it essentially it
says you cannot do something that is
outside the expectation of the consumer
and I think we are experiencing this
across technology which is you know
aerial vehicles are not unique to the
privacy issue our mobile phones with
cameras helicopters you know camera on a
stick these things are all have the
potential to
you know invade you know our privacy so
I think the reality is that the industry
is ready to work with the government
work with the NTIA on developing real
clear standards on privacy